IAN URBINA: So my
name is Ian Urbina.
I'm a reporter at "The Times,"
have been there since 2003.
And I do investigative projects.
And that was always sort of my
dream when I joined the paper,
and have been doing that
for about five, six years.
And essentially
what that means is
I have the luxury of
time with stories.
So I'm not a beat
reporter and I don't
have to sort of sprint every
day to help fill the page,
feed the beast as we say.
I can go longer
and work on things.
The expectation though that
comes with that luxury of time
is that you will find
virgin snow, topically,
which basically means old
topics but a new angle on them,
or new information that
previously wasn't disclosed,
or both.
And that there will
be a level of polish
and a level of rigor
in what you produce
that is higher than would
be expected from someone
that had three days as opposed
to three months to produce.
So this series was one
that I had pitched.
I'd been kind of fantasizing
about getting the Gray
Lady to pay to send
me to sea, had long
been kind of a dream of mine.
In grad school I
worked on a ship.
And since I was a boy I was
always sort of fascinated
by the blue on the globe and
sort of the little specks
in the middle of the
ocean, who lives there,
and how to get there, and what's
it like being a teenager there,
and can I ever go there.
So I had pitched
the notion of our
doing a series on this
several times before.
It's insanely expensive
and sometimes dangerous.
And so previous
editors had kind of
looked at me quizzically and
said, OK, what else you got?
But this editor
liked the thought
and essentially said
sure, write me a memo.
Let's see what story ideas
we would actually do.
And the pitch was really simple.
It was just this thought
that 2/3 of the planet's
covered by water.
And much of that space is
ungoverned and ungovernable,
in my view.
And wouldn't it be amazing if
we could take our readers out
there to that space, a place
that they probably had never
been and may never get
to go, and just talk
about what happens out there.
And the import is
90% of everything
we consume comes to
us by way of sea.
50% of the oxygen we
breathe comes by way of sea.
And it's just a strange
kind of last frontier
the commons, the tragedy of
the commons, outer space,
and international waters and
Antarctica, there a couple
places around that people can
access that sort of belongs
to everyone and no one.
And the high seas
are one of them.
So that was the thought.
That was the pitch.
My editor liked it.
And off we went.
It quickly became a
little bit more specific.
It wasn't just sort
of let's go out
there and see what's out there.
It was more let's
look at the range
of bad behavior, the crime
that occurs out there, and not
just environmental crime.
In fact when I first pitched
it, as I left the office
sort of shocked that I had
made it past first base
on this, as I left my
editor-- her name is Rebecca
Corbett-- said, and by
the way, let's think
about an ocean series.
But I don't want any fish.
And I remember thinking-- I
turned back and said wait,
so you want a series about
the oceans but no fish?
And this was
brilliant in my view.
What she meant
was that space out
there is covered often as
an environmental story,
and for obvious reasons.
But let's approach it-- we
can back our way into that,
but let's approach it as a
human story, a labor story,
human rights story, and look
for those stories primarily.
And then secondarily,
look at the space
as a kind of marine realm that
we're depleting and despoiling.
So I'm going to blitz through.
There are eight big stories.
I think I'll probably get
through maybe five of them.
I can't imagine
anyone working here
has enough time to
have read them all.
So I'll just talk
about sort of what
my goal was, tactics
were, findings
were for each of the stories.
And then I'll stop.
So when you're going
to do a big series,
you're sort of planning
out how to do these things,
the first story in the series is
often referred to as the throat
clear.
And it needs to be
clearing your throat
to get the attention
of the room,
in this case, kind of
your reading public.
And so it has to be kind
of an altitude that's
much higher in terms
of its perspective
and sort of authoritative tone
and a level of polish that's
beyond the rest of the pieces,
because you really kind of have
to establish kind of the
corners of your canvas.
So this first story
aimed at that.
And it had, at
its root, one kind
of core conceit, if you will,
from a writing perspective.
And that was, my thought was,
rather than having a person
as the main character
in the story,
let's have a ship as
the main character.
And let's find a ship that is a
well documented and repeat bad
actor and kind of a poster child
of scofflaw behavior at sea.
And then let's sort of
let's just follow that ship
as it goes around the
planet and does bad stuff.
And so I kind of
had a beauty contest
if you will-- the opposite of
beauty contest, an ugly contest
for the contestants
that we might
choose from for this
story and looked
at a bunch of different, really
well documented bad ships where
bad stuff had happened.
And the "Dona Liberta,"
that's called the "Sea Pearl"
in this picture.
And you can go in on some of
these photos and sort of blow
up the actual photo
and maybe scroll
through some of the photos.
It says the "Sea Pearl" now.
It's renamed.
It's actually has since
been renamed again.
But so the "Dona Liberta" was
the one that won the contest.
And it won because
it had engaged
in-- you want to jump
past the autoplay one
and scroll all the way down.
It engaged in three categories
of crimes that struck me
as either really compelling
and dramatic and/or
pervasive and important.
One was abuse of stowaways.
So the story there is this.
The "Dona Liberta" is a
small ship, Greek owned.
At the time it was
Italian captained, mostly
Romanian crew.
It's called a mother ship.
It's a refrigeration ship.
It mostly transports
tuna from fishing vessels
to shore between countries.
Real run down, broken
down ship, should
have been retired decades ago.
And there are a couple
places in the world
that have robust stowaway
communities, repeat fliers.
And Cape Town is kind
of the top of that list,
for a bunch of reasons.
It's port is porous.
A lot of really big ships
come in and out of there.
A lot of poor countries
in the neighborhood
that put out these guys.
They're all guys, or
at least all the ones
I have ever read or interviewed.
And so there's a
robust shanty town
that's just always or kind
of aspiring stowaways or just
return stowaways right in Cape
Town, right near the port.
And so "Dona Liberta" was
in port 2011 in Cape Town.
These two Tanzanian
guys, one of whom
had stowed away a
couple times before,
once or twice
quite successfully,
landed someplace nice.
Stayed there, got a
girlfriend, a job,
undocumented, had a life way
better than what he was living
before, and then got caught
by immigration and sent back,
tried again.
That was one guy.
The other guy had
never done it before.
They team up.
They sneak onto
the "Dona Liberta."
They hide out in
the engine room.
They make it a couple days.
They're discovered,
brought up on deck.
And the captain says to
the crew, deal with them.
OK, so let's pause everything.
That moment in the movie is
kind of an important moment
conceptually because post-9/11,
the world became scared
and regulations came down
in every realm, airports,
et cetera, including ports.
And one of those regulations
was you show up with guys
on your ship that aren't
supposed to be there,
you're going to be hit with
huge fines because of terrorism
concerns.
And so all these ports sort of
implemented these regulations
that had hefty fines.
The fines go to the company.
The company passes the
fines down to the captains.
And the captains
say, you guys are
responsible for the
sweep of the ship
before we leave
port to make sure
that there are no stowaways.
And if you guys don't
do a good job at that,
it's coming out of your wages
if we get hit with a fine.
The fines can be
$50,000 $100,000.
These guys make
$40,000 $50,000 a year.
It's serious business.
So our Tanzanian guys somehow
slipped in, didn't get nabbed.
So the captain in a very--
the captain turned to the crew
and said something
that we had heard
was said often in this
situation post 9/11.
You guys deal with them.
I don't want to know how.
Deal with them.
What that means is
get rid of them.
And the more humane
way you get rid
of them-- obviously
there's some instances
where they deal with
them by the book.
They bring them back in port.
They take the fines,
et cetera, et cetera.
There are also sort of other
ways, which are you just kill
them, throw him overboard.
And then there's the
middle ground which
is you try to humanely deal
with him by doing what happened
to these guys, which was
they built a raft, tabletop
raft, about eight by
eight, handles, real flat,
drums underneath, oil drums.
Put it on the water.
Tether it to the "Dona
Liberta" way off at sea.
Bring the guys up from lockdown.
Say climb on board.
They cut the cord.
And storms coming
on the horizon.
"Dona Liberta" steams away.
These guys are out there,
don't know how to swim,
and they're sort of holding on.
I had heard about this incident
from an Interpol source
and thought wow,
that's dramatic.
We didn't know the name of
the guys, the stowaways.
We didn't know much.
So thus began the scramble,
the fear, all that.
We got lucky.
And the raft survived out
there for a while, washed up
in Liberia.
Both guys were alive
when they came ashore.
One of the guys
was in bad shape.
He died 24 hours later.
The other guy survived.
And that was crime
number one and the reason
I was really interested
in "Dona Liberta."
If we could find that survivor
guy and land his story,
that becomes cinematic
drama, and important news.
Because in the 9/11 moment,
it's an interesting problem,
and also part of the
lawlessness at sea concept.
Second crime that "Dona Liberta"
engaged in-- every three years,
ships intentionally
dump more oil and sludge
into the oceans than the BP and
"Exxon Valdez" spill combined.
So think about that,
how much coverage there
was of those two accidents.
And then think about the
fact that intentionally
the sheer quantity
is every three
years put into the oceans.
The oceans are a big place.
Dilution's real.
But it accumulates.
A lot of the stuff
doesn't biodegrade.
So I thought when we
crunched those numbers
and found out that
statistic, I thought
wow, that's pretty striking.
The "Dona Liberta" was
caught on satellite
doing just that, something
called a magic pipe.
A lot of ships have it,
runs from your engine
room under the ship.
And it's essentially a flush.
It's not what you're
supposed to do.
You're supposed to
bring the stuff back
to shore, have that
processed, costs.
A lot of folks have
magic pipes installed
so they can get rid of the
waste cheaply and disappear it.
"Dona Liberta" had a magic pipe.
They caused a 90 mile
slick off the coast
of Africa, caught
doing it on satellite.
Category two.
Category three, less
dramatic, very pervasive,
abuse of mariners,
of deck hands.
And it's low grade abuse in
terms of the drama scale.
It's wage theft and
its abandonment.
But it's a big problem.
Most of these crews--
we're not talking
about "Captain Phillips,"
Maersk container ships.
We're talking about
"Dona Liberta," shitty,
smaller kind of craft
that really make up
the true numbers
of people and ships
out on the world's
oceans-- not US waters,
but the rest of the world.
And what happens often
with these companies
and these ships is the
corporate structure
is kind of something
out of a crime movie.
It's like a PO box registered
to a guy who doesn't exist,
licensed in Nigeria,
owned by a guy in Greece.
It's layers upon layers
and intentionally
designed to be
impossible to figure out
who actually owns that company
that owns that company that
owns that ship.
"Dona Liberta" was
a textbook example
of this, papers and kind of
companies on top of companies,
some of which don't even exist.
And what happens often in these
cases is a ship rolls into port
or comes into port and
gets hit with some fine,
or some unpaid bill
catches up with them,
or the mother company
is moving money around
and hits some problem.
And overnight it
becomes in the interest
of the company to basically
disappear, cut their losses
and walk.
And so they do that.
And the corporate culture
is almost built for that.
But there are guys on the
ship out there in, wherever,
and they're kind of at a loss.
A quarter of the
world's mariners
are from the Philippines.
Interesting backstory as
to why that's the case.
But most of these folks
are third worlders,
developing world crew.
So they don't have
the resources.
They don't have the lobby.
They don't have the lawyers.
They don't have anything to
really kind of logistically
figure their way home.
They're on a ship that
no longer has an owner.
They can't get any
calls answered.
They don't have the
money or the papers
to get off because they're on
the coast of the US or Europe
or Africa or wherever.
They're not allowed
off the ship.
They're a mile off shore and
they're in port sometimes.
And the ship can't
move and leave
because they don't
have the fuel.
So they're stuck.
And these stories
get very dramatic.
Guys have died,
starved to death.
A lot of guys have tried to swim
to shore and they can't swim,
they get drowned.
They sneak in the country.
They get nabbed for
immigration, et cetera.
A big problem in the seafarer
world, and the "Dona Liberta"
had engaged in this
crime repeatedly.
So we tracked down
one of the former crew
in this tiny town in Romania
who had experienced just that.
So that's the "Dona Liberta".
And that was sort of the
first story in the series.
So why don't we pull out
and go to the second story?
So I reported these differently
than we published them.
And this second
story was a story
that I reported towards
the end of the process.
And I bring that up because
in the course of reporting
these other stories, the
"Dona Liberta" and others,
I kept hearing about just
this insane level of violence
at sea.
And there are a couple things
I kept hearing or inferring.
One was the type of
violence that we know of,
the sort of "Captain Phillips,"
RPG, fast boat Somali attack
on Western well endowed
kind of merchant vessels
is a tiny, tiny, tiny sliver of
really what happens out there
in terms of incidents,
in terms of bodies,
in terms of dollars lost,
in terms of just brutality.
But it's kind of what we
consume in the Western world,
dramatic, and it's
the story that
made it onto the silver screen.
So it's what we all know.
And it was a real, real problem
in '08, '09, '10, but kind
of has subsided since then.
The real realm of violence
is the "Dona Liberta" kind
of level of ship.
And it's places you
wouldn't expect.
Bangladesh, the
waters off Bangladesh,
probably some of the most
violent waters on the planet.
Bay of Bengal, this
area called Sundarbans,
if you actually look at
the numbers of kidnappings,
hundred at a times put in these
villages and held for ransom.
South China Sea, coast
of West Africa, these
are some really brutal places.
And it's usually fishing
boat and fishing boat,
big boat on small boat,
fuel vessel, localized gangs
who specialize in this.
It's armed robbery at sea.
And there are
kidnapping rackets.
All right, point one.
Point two, so the
type of violence,
the target of violence, the
motivation of the violence
was different than kind of I
thought the public realized.
And number two, the
"Captain Phillips" narrative
was actually often
used as a cover
for other types of violence.
And I'll explain that a
little bit more in a second.
So I wanted to do
something on violence.
But when you write
a 5,000 word story,
you can't write an article.
You have to write a story.
It's got to be a
narrative or else
your reader is not
going to actually sit
with you unless they're like
a professor of such and such
and they care a lot about it.
But that's five people.
If you really want
real people to read it,
then you have to
make it a narrative.
So this violence one
was really tough.
I couldn't figure out how
to make it a narrative.
I don't think I achieved it.
But I wrote an article.
But the thing that did
land in my lap that
made it a pretty striking
article was this video.
So I was on the South China
Sea for six weeks, photographer
and I, reporting a separate
story, the sea slavery story.
And I got an email from a kind
of spooky law enforcement type
who I've known for a
long time and trust.
And he trusts me.
And he sends me stuff.
And he's a real serious guy.
He never pops into
my inbox unless it's
something pretty heavy.
We worked together on sex
trafficking of minors, global,
kind of really brutal stuff.
So when the email
came in, I'd been
out on boats in Indonesia
and Borneo for a while.
And I was kind of worn out
and emotionally at wits end.
And the email subject
line said brace yourself.
And that's like really
superlative language
from this guy.
And I thought, if
he says that, then
what am I about to open in
this video that's in the email?
So I thought for a
second, should I open it?
And of course I did.
What it is, is a 10 minute
and 26 second long video.
It was on a cell phone.
It was found in the back of
a taxi in Fiji by a student.
The student saw it and
started scrolling through it,
saw this video.
The video shows four
men in the water.
Can't tell where--
we figured out
where-- kind of flailing
about trying to get away.
And in the surrounding
are four large ships
that turn out to be Taiwanese
tuna long liners, big ships.
The guys in the water are brown.
Grainy, cell phone video, can't
make out ethnicity exactly,
but they don't look
Scandinavian, put it that way.
And there's wreckage, wooden
wreckage in the water.
And some of them
are clinging to it.
Others are trying to flee.
And what proceeds
in the 10 minutes
is killing, a brutal
killing, where
someone with a semiautomatic
who was behind the camera
essentially takes
these guys out.
It takes some work.
It's not a great shot, but
head shots, a lot of blood.
And at the end, as if
that wasn't bad enough,
there's a celebration
where the deckhands
where they all kind of cheer.
And they pose for selfies.
So I get this video and
think, OK, well there's
my violence story.
You know, I'm going to
investigate the hell out
of this video and figure
out what happened if we can.
So we did.
Well, we'll look at
a quick clip of it.
But the real crime
in my view occurred
after we published the
story, which is not before,
even though we went to Fiji.
We went to Taiwan.
We went to all the relevant
players and leaned on them
and brought diplomats to
bear and the State Department
and Interpol, every
pressure tactic
I know to get a government
to step up and do something
about this.
None of them were willing
to investigate it.
And then after the
story we thought
OK, this will shame a
government into doing something.
To this day no governments
are willing to investigate.
Not because it's
so hot or scary.
This isn't the My Lai
massacre or anything,
but because no one cares
really, I mean, crassly put.
More sophisticated
is to say, it kind of
gets to the nature
of the high seas.
On a ship you have maybe
10 different nationalities.
It's tied to three
other countries.
And the people on board,
either the deckhands
who are conducting the
crime or the victims of it,
are typically poor
and not the types
who have a government that's
going to go to bat for them.
In this case what
was interesting--
now we loop all the way
back to "Captain Phillips--"
the governments that
we really leaned on,
Taiwan in particular, Fiji
also, said we've looked into it.
We didn't open a
formal investigation,
but we looked into this.
We looked at the
evidence you have.
And we've come to the conclusion
that the guys in the water
were pirates.
The guys in the water-- you
can see the front of one
of the Taiwanese two
longliners in that picture.
The guys in the water could
be Attila the Hun's cousins
for all I care.
There's no way that those
guys are still threats.
This is murder period.
And so it brought
me back to something
I had been inferring for the
entire year of reporting.
And now was like a
perfect example of it
where piracy, Somali piracy, the
fear of the rhetoric around it
was now being used
as a pretext to not
do anything about something
that was clearly a murder.
So that was the core
ingredient of that story.
And because I'm way
over time, I don't
think we'll watch the video.
But I encourage you
to keep me employed
and go to the website
an click there.
The other thing that was
in this story-- and again,
it was not a narrative.
It was sort of a hodgepodge.
It was something else that
struck me as fascinating,
maybe you guys too.
So post-9/11, a lot of new rules
came down around the world,
including in the maritime
space, one of which was--
let's do it the other way.
So post 2008, 2009, Somali
piracy, serious problem,
more attention, big players
getting hit, scary stuff
happening.
And the industry, shipping
industry, turned to governments
and said we know
you've long-- i.e.
two centuries-- had a policy of
discouraging weapons on board.
Everyone's got guns
on board, but kind
of discouraging the conspicuous
display or use of armed power
on private vessels.
But we're getting
our ass kicked here.
And we need some help.
And the governments said
OK we'll look into it.
And then governments looked
back to the Navy guys
and realized they had
reduced their Navy power.
And there are jurisdictional
issues and all sorts of--
and they're like, we're
not in the business
of doing law enforcement.
We're kind of protecting
geopolitical issues
and other stuff,
but we're not cops.
And so governments turned
back to the industry and said,
look, sorry, you've got
to deal with it yourself.
Literally in six
months a $20 billion
industry emerged,
Blackwater on the oceans.
So the private maritime security
industry was born in 12 months
and became this
massive industry.
And it was a lot of
exsoldiers, a fair number
of British American ex-Iraq,
ex-Afghanistan soldiers,
and a huge number of
Pakistanis and Sri Lankans.
Sri Lankan are a really
interesting story.
They got ahead of
this, partially
because of where they are.
They're real close to a lot
of the rough neighborhoods.
But they cornered a big
chunk of the market.
And a lot of Tamil
Tigers-- anyone
who knows Sri Lanka, you get
a lot of demobilized Sinhalese
government soldiers and
a lot of former rebels
who had training in arms
went into the business.
And that's some of where the
worst behavior is coming from,
including the shooter
in this video.
At least that's what I
concluded and others concluded.
So on the one hand
you had governments,
in writing, including
the US government,
turning to the industry and
saying OK, arm yourselves.
You need guys with guns.
So companies emerged and
they had guys with guns.
For man teams initially, then
insurers said three is fine.
Now we're down to two man teams.
And most of the guards
say that's insane.
Some of these ships are two,
three football fields large.
And when they get hit, they get
hit from four different boats,
different directions.
Two guys cannot handle that.
So they said arms yourselves.
And that was one
phenomena, '08, '09.
The other phenomena
was post 9/11,
ports saying no guys with guns,
like all over the world saying,
look we're afraid.
Mumbai was hit by guys on boats.
And there was just
a general fear
of terrorists coming by boat.
So the world said OK, we've
got to figure something out.
The port guy, what
do you suggest we do?
I say we have a new rule
that says no guys with guns
come in our national waters.
National waters are
12 miles from shore.
International start at 13.
So all these countries passed
these rules, no guys with guns.
So what happened?
You got lots of guys with guns
and no guys with guns allowed.
So what they started
doing the first 12 months
is they just dumped the
guns, keep the guys.
So whenever they entered,
you got stuff-- grain,
fuel, Nike shoes,
whatever, Apple computers.
They come into port, dump
the guns at 13, sink them.
Come into port, unload.
Come back out, there's a
gun dealer at 13, 14, 15.
Buy new guns, off you go.
It was cheaper than
dealing with all
the red tape and [INAUDIBLE].
But then some
smart entrepreneurs
were like, that's crazy.
We've got a better system.
So they created this business
called floating armories, which
are these boats which are
usually 13, 15, 20 miles out.
And they're just one part
bunk house, one part gun demo.
And you essentially take
your guys with guns.
You unload them.
They stay there in
between deployments.
And it's this weird place.
And of course I
wanted to get there.
That's when I'm in
the business of doing
is finding weird places
and trying to get there.
And so a photographer and I
went to some of these floating
armories and stayed there.
Partially just to
access the guards
and hear what they had to
say about violence, but also
just to see what this
niche business was like,
and also what it could tell
us about the types of violence
that are out there, the types
of arms dealing, et cetera.
All right, so that's the
hodgepodge to number two story.
We're at 28 minutes.
I'm going to stop at 40.
The third story was a
story about sea slavery,
which is sort of a loaded term.
And it generally refers
to, in the maritime space,
trafficked and/or child and/or
forced and/or indentured labor
on boats.
Think of it as a
spectrum, right?
So you've got soft to hard.
On the soft end, you
have maybe indentured.
So that is-- what that looks
like-- so a couple points.
One, a lot of attention has
been paid to sea slavery
in the last 20 months,
good attention.
It's worthy of it.
It's mostly focused on the
South China Sea and Thailand,
which is where we went to.
That's a problem.
Because truth be told,
it is a global problem.
You go off the
coast of Falklands,
you go off the coast
of New Zealand,
go off the coast of
South Korea, you go off
the coast of West Africa, Bay
of Bengal again, Indonesia,
you will find the same and
worse problems of this.
And what it looks like--
But Thailand's a really
interesting case,
and here's why.
Thailand is essentially
a middle class country.
It's got less than
2% unemployment.
If you're Thai, you don't take
jobs in the shit industries.
So you won't find Thai
women, for the most part,
in the sex industry.
And you won't find Thai
men, for the most part,
on fishing boats.
But those two industries
are the biggest money makers
in Thailand.
And they depend almost entirely
on Cambodian, Laotian, Burmese,
Rohingya, import,
undocumented, indebted labor.
Those surrounding countries
are super poor, super unstable,
and big out pushers of people.
So what we had heard was there
was an interesting intersection
between sort of environmental
and labor issues in Thailand,
and everywhere.
But Thailand is a
great place for it
because what you had was
in the last two decades,
there's been so much
overfishing close
to shore that the stocks of fish
are depleted closer to shore.
It can take two days to
catch what it took two
hours to catch two decades ago.
So ships were having
to go much further
out from shore to reach quota.
And there's a point at which
the economics don't make sense,
because fuel is
your base expense.
And if you get so far out,
you can't catch enough fish
to break even.
So that is what led to something
called transshipment, which
is essentially a system where
these fishing vessels, big ones
like your tuna ships
there, transshipment
is the system where the fishing
boats go way out 200, 250,
300 miles from shore,
and they stay out there.
And they just keep fishing.
And they don't come back in.
And mother ships like the
"Dona Liberta" go out.
They bring ice, fuel, food,
parts, drugs, women out,
and they bring
fish back-- labor.
And the vessels
just keep fishing.
What we had learned
was that if you
want to find really egregious,
like yesteryear type slavery,
go to the transhipment vessels.
Go way out.
Those are the ones who are--
because for obvious reasons,
because they're
staying out there.
They're way beyond the
reach of any government,
and they're just
fishing all the time.
So our goal, the
photographer, a guy
named Adam Dean, an amazing
photographer as you can see,
and I was to see if we
could get on these vessels.
And it took some work, took a
lot of time and luck and rats
and roaches.
But eventually we got out
onto several, one of which
was the one that
we really profiled,
which was a kind of textbook
example of this model, which
was four officers, all Thai.
One bo's'n, he's
your middle man.
On a plantation
he's the guy that
is-- he's of the ethnicity
of the forced labor,
but he answers to and gets
to stay in the big house.
So the bo's'n on the ship.
And he is always going to be
of the ethnicity of the crew.
And the crew is never
going to be the officers.
So on these ships, the officers
are all Thai, only speak Thai.
On this ship the crew of
40, mostly boys, some men,
all Cambodian, all indentured,
two shanghaied-- meaning
went to a bar, talking to
a prostitute, passed out.
Next thing they know
they're on a ship.
And the bo's'n is Cambodian.
So he speaks both
Thai-- and he's
the guy that beats
people, kills people.
And I say kills people
like in passing.
So in '09, just so you don't
think I'm being hyperbolic,
in 2009 the UN did a survey of
this demographic in the South
China Sea, these boats--
escaped crew, rescued crew--
and found that 59% of them--
and this was a peer review,
kind of vetted survey.
59% of them had
witnessed a murder
by officers on crew-- 59%.
I'd done coal, trucking,
sex trafficking,
like really dark
spaces on the planet.
I'd never seen the
level of brutality
that you'll find
these type of boats.
So we went out and
made it on this boat
and spent time out there and
essentially sort of documented,
how did you get here?
What's work like?
What are the conditions?
And this story was a
close look at the problem
of this kind of
labor, and sought
to-- whether we
achieved it or not, go
read it and you be the judge.
But I'll sort of explain it
from the captain's perspective.
Why are you so insanely brutal
and you kill people or beat
the hell out of them if there's
even the slightest kind of hint
of insubordination?
Why do you think
it's fair that you
can take a person,
what we would call
slavery-- what do you call it?
What they call it is a
simple labor contract.
A broker came to them.
The kid came to the border
with the trafficker.
The kid didn't have any money.
And these are kids.
I mean, you look at these
pictures-- the captain said
they're all over 17.
I don't how well
you can see these.
But look at the faces on
these kids, they're 13 maybe.
And there, the
captain's view is look,
I paid the labor broker,
trafficker, $400-- huge amount
of money-- for this guy.
And I'm out that money.
This guy is going to work
for me to pay back that debt.
Now of course what's ridiculous
about that is you leave port,
there's no like bookkeeping.
Hey Johnny, you earn
$20 today working.
You leave port, you're on
that ship as long as it takes.
So for example in
this same story,
not on that ship
but a prior ship,
we focused on one
guy named Lang Long.
Secretary Kerry and
others have sort of
picked up Lang Long's story and
run with it, which is great.
It's what you want
as a journalist.
But Land Long was this
very well vetted case
that we found of a
guy who was shackled
by the neck for two
years at sea, sold
between three different boats.
Standard kind of--
he's Cambodian,
came in through traffickers.
He thought he was getting
a job in construction,
ends up on a boat,
et cetera, et cetera.
Tried to escape when a mother
ship came out, jumped over, got
brought back on board.
And whenever he wasn't
working he was in a shackle.
And this isn't me saying it,
this is a separate mothership
came out and a guy saw that and
said, what the hell is this,
and proceeded over
the next nine months
to report back to an advocacy
group, the Thai government,
and negotiate the purchase
of that guy off the ship.
And Lang Long was someone
that whose story we landed,
had him in the story.
So anyway, so this was the
third-- three minutes--
the third story in the series,
probably one of the toughest
to report.
So let's pull out
and let me just
figure out what would be the
best one to move to next,
and finally.
So let's do that one.
This was one of those stories
that you almost kind of
are a channel for.
I didn't write this story,
this story wrote through me.
It was just a great yarn.
And it spoke to larger
issues about lawlessness,
but here's the story.
So again, I got a call
when I was out at sea.
I had a satellite phone.
I got a call from a
source, a law enforcement
person who knew I was on the
market for really good maritime
stories.
The person said, have you
heard about this chase?
No.
It's the longest chase
in nautical history.
And it's a law
enforcement chase,
but there are no cops involved.
I said OK, I'm sold.
How do I get on it?
Is it going on now?
Yes.
So the story is
simply that there's
this group, you guys probably
know them, Sea Shepherd.
It's an offshoot of Greenpeace,
a more radical, direct action
group.
They're on the
show "Whale Wars."
They've had all sorts of run ins
with the Japanese government,
well-funded, Hollywood kind of
backed sort of marine advocacy
group.
They have a bunch of ships.
And they kind of conducted
an interesting experiment,
which was so Interpol has a
list called the purple list.
And it is the list you get on
as a ship if you're really bad.
And you have to work to
get on the purple list.
But it's an arrest
on sight list.
And at the time there
were only seven ships
in the world that were on
Interpol's purple list.
And essentially if
you're on that list,
every country in the world
is supposed to stop you.
No one ever does.
The top of that list was a
ship called the "Thunder."
and the reason it
had top ranking
was because it had
earned $67 million
worth of money
poaching, stealing fish
from places it
wasn't supposed to,
mostly from
Antarctica and mostly
Chilean sea bass, more
commonly known as toothfish.
You buy it at restaurants,
high end restaurants, hotels.
So the "Thunder," which is
the one that's sinking there,
had a decade and a
half of stealing fish.
And Sea Shepherd
said you know what,
we're sick of governments
not doing anything
about these guys.
They're right there.
Everyone knows about them.
No one stops them.
We're going to go out and
find the seven purple list
vessels, wherever
they are in the world,
and we're going to chase them.
And we're just
going to chase them.
And we're going to raise
holy hell every time
they try to come into port.
That was it.
That was their goal.
And literally when they
kind of floated the idea
within the maritime
community, some people sort of
rolled their eyes, like
good luck finding them.
Within two weeks, Sea
Shepherd in Antarctica
found the "Thunder,"
nets in the water.
And how they did that is really
interesting, to me at least.
But they did it.
And they began chasing them.
And thus began a
10,000 mile chase
that went from Antarctica
to the coast of Africa.
And it's like this
epic, cinematic story.
The "Thunder" tried
to shake their chasers
by going through this
really impossibly
dangerous area of
icebergs in Antarctica--
couldn't shake them.
Two ships, the "Bob
Barker" and the "Sam
Simon--" I'm not making it up.
Those are the names.
Those are the benefactors.
These ships just chased them.
They went through a
category five storm.
We have footage on the website
of the insane conditions.
Couldn't shake them.
Tried to outrun them.
At one point the Sea Shepherd
guys, the "Thunder" guys
needed food.
Well we don't know
why they did it,
but they put nets
back in the water.
And the Sea Shepherd guys
said we're taking your nets.
And they went out,
they took their nets,
pulled them on board.
The "Thunder" captain--
we have the audio of it.
He's a Chilean and I speak
Spanish, so I listened to it.
But he, profanity
laden pissed, and says
we're coming after you.
So for six straight
hours, the "Thunder"
chased the Sea Shepherd guys.
So it's just like you
can't make these stories.
I was like, I'm not sure I
can live up to the story.
I don't even have to get this
story, I just have to write it.
So this was this great story.
And again, it fit perfectly
in my conceptual umbrella
of lawlessness out in the void.
And I left and headed home
thinking wow, how can I get
that into 5,000 words or less.
I'm at Amsterdam or somewhere,
I can't remember where,
but a layover.
I get a call.
You're not going
to believe what's
happening to the "Thunder."
And I thought, the story's
already dramatic enough.
And I left before it had
culminated because it
was going on and on and on.
And it wasn't clear when they
were going to stop running.
And they might get refueled
by some sketchy Nigerians
that they were heading towards.
And I was just like, this
is going to go on forever.
So I left.
I get a call.
You're not going to
believe what's happening.
The "Thunder's" sinking.
And literally I remember turning
to the board, the big board--
you, know, airports--
and trying to figure out,
can i get back to Ghana?
Is there any way to
get back to this?
Obviously I couldn't.
It took days and days
to get out there.
So the "Thunder"
ultimately sunk itself.
The crew got off.
The officers got off.
What's the word?
I'm having a stroke here.
They're rescued by
the Sea Shepherd
guys, taken to Sao
Tome and Principe,
handed over to the police.
They've since been
prosecuted, convicted.
The officers are looking at
two years and $5 million.
The crew just following orders,
all Indonesian, sent home.
But that ending I never
would have predicted
and is the perfect sort
of capstone to the story,
because down with it,
a mile and a half,
went the evidence
of their crimes.
Now they got
prosecuted, so it ended
in a way that often
doesn't happen.
But many of these
stories end this way
where, when the jig is up,
you just sink the evidence,
and it's very hard to
prove things at sea.
And that gets, again, to the
difficulty of law enforcement
on these waters.
So I'm going to ungracefully
and really abruptly stop there.
There are about four other
stories in the series.
I think it's better to just
open up the Q&A and we can talk.
So thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
You have the first.
AUDIENCE: Thanks
for writing these.
I've really enjoyed them.
I spent a lot of time on small
boats in nice neighborhoods.
So I have a hard time kind
of thinking of a world
where I see a lot of
kindness and people
help you if you're in
trouble and so on with this.
Is it really a matter
of bad neighborhoods,
or have I just been sheltered?
And what do you think?
IAN URBINA: It's
a good question.
So it's such a huge
space that most of what
happens out there, in my
view, is people staying away
from each other, by design,
by decision, or just
by the nature of how big it is.
So the bad stuff isn't
all the time, everywhere.
It's not packed in.
At the same time, what struck
me wasn't the frequency,
it was the impunity.
And so I wouldn't
try to put a number.
We did with the
violence story and we
crunched all sorts
of data and tried
to get some estimates on how
often that stuff happens.
And the numbers are
pretty striking.
Take a look at that story and
what we had was very partial.
But what I will say is
there are some places
in the world and some
orders of vessels where
it's a really brutal place.
So I would say if you're
looking to find bad stuff, go
get a job on a Taiwanese
tuna longliner,
or many of these mother ships
that service the third world.
The discipline that's
exerted on the crew
and what happens on those
boats is pretty severe.
So I don't think it's
just where you are,
I also think it's the
type of vessel you're on.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks
for writing that series.
I really enjoyed it.
So the sea has
historically been a place
of both danger and criminality,
but also adventure.
I was wondering is the fact
that in this day and age
it still exists as like a Wild
West of lawlessness-- obviously
you've exposed a lot of the
horrible stuff that goes on
out there.
Is there any tinge
of romance left to it
that there's an ungoverned
place left on Earth?
IAN URBINA: Yeah, I think
you put it really gracefully.
And it is something that
I give short shrift to,
because sort of by
the nature of my beat,
I'm supposed to focus
on what's broken.
I have a 12-year-old,
and he's always like,
Dad, another negative story.
You know, why can't you--
I'm like, this is what I do.
So just to riff
on what you said,
there's this notion of
"Mare Liberum," which
is sort of in some ways
a conceptual precursor
to international law.
And this Dutch lawyer named
Grotius came up with it.
And it was kind of what gave
rise intellectually and legally
to free trade.
And it had lots of
components, one of which
was hey look guys, us
governments that are starting
to form, let's agree that
we leave each other alone
out in that space,
the high seas area.
And the 12 is interesting.
It's a cannon shot.
That's where that
number originally came.
So when people get too close and
they can hit you with a cannon,
that's national waters.
But out beyond that, it's
international waters.
And let's have that be
a kind of public space
where we don't mess
with each other.
And let's all agree that those
guys that do, the, pirates, we
will team up together
to kick their ass.
Like that's the core
and really crass version
of "Mare Liberum."
And it's also the core of
just what you hint at, which
is the romance, which is real.
It's a beautiful space.
It's an open space.
It's really kind of an
embodiment of freedom
because of its huge expanse.
And it's also an essential
space for commerce in the sense
that part of the way that
a designer in New York
can think up a new
style of dress,
and a week later it's
on a monitor in Taiwan,
and a week after that it's being
mass produced in Bangladesh,
and the dye is
coming from Tokyo,
and then it's in a
container on a ship
and headed back to
New York for sale
a week after that, part of the
way you can have rapid commerce
is because there are
no checkpoints and toll
booths on the high seas.
That's why 90% of commerce
comes by way of sea,
because it's fast-- relatively.
Not as fast as a plane--
and cheap and unfettered.
So from a philosophical
point of view
it is a beautiful place
where people go, historically
and presently, to get
away from governments
and to get away from people.
But it's also an
economic thruway
that, because it's
lawless, is essential
to globalized markets.
And I obviously didn't
spend much time on that,
but I do really
think you're right.
AUDIENCE: So I know this is
kind of going against your--
I was going to bring
up a point that was
against your editorial dictate.
But in addition to all of
these bad issues of slavery
on the high seas and violence
and brutality and everything
else, there's also sort of
the environmental issues
of them using bunker fuel, also
with like scrubbers systems
whatsoever.
So one really big ship can
put out as much pollution
as all the cars
in New York City.
So what's the point of
fixing things on land
if the ships are so polluting?
So just with all
those issues, and it
tinges on human rights and the
environment and everything,
can anything actually be
done to solve these problems,
or is there anything
that's going to be done?
Or is it just permanently
kind of a lawless land
and let it be?
IAN URBINA: Yes, a lot
can, and already is,
and each day I think
is more being done
on the environmental front.
And I would think that there
are two different categories
of environmental concerns.
There's above water
and below water.
So above water, like you say,
the type of fuel that's burnt
is really, really polluting.
And there are large
quantities of it.
And below water,
technology has meant
that fishing has become more
like industrial harvesting
and less like fishing.
So you have bigger ships, more
effective ships, better sonar,
better GPS.
It's a glass top
table now, and you
can see everything down below.
And so what that has meant
in the last three decades--
and if you would jump
to the Palau story.
It's the very last story
Craig, the very last story.
So the very last
story, which I ended up
going to the magazine to
do, is the fish story.
It's the environmental story.
And it's about this tiny
archipelago nation of Palau
which has the landmass
of Philadelphia
and the water space of France.
And they have one
ship and 18 men.
And that country, Palau,
has been more aggressive
probably than any
country in the world,
for lots of
self-interested reasons.
50% of the GDP
comes from tourism,
and that's all water tourism.
That's shark and coral.
And they're in a rough
neighborhood in terms
of poachers, near
the biggest markets,
both the biggest fleets and
the biggest consumers of fish
in the world are
all around them .
So you've got this in
amazing David and Goliath
or Sisyphus story, whichever
way you want to go.
And so I went.
That's not their ship.
Thankfully that's one of
the ships they boarded,
the one you're seeing.
But I went for an embed with
that kind of police force
and sort of used that
synecdoche as sort
of what might the world learn
about the importance of getting
a handle on how
quickly we're depleting
the ocean of its residents
and what we can now,
in the era of big data
and drones and satellites,
potentially do to
police those waters.
And Google, your employer,
is actually in the story
and is playing an important
role on the big data front.
You may already know about that.
So to answer your
question, yeah, I
think there's a lot
that can be done.
I do think technology
in particular
can be a force for good
in slowing technology's
role in the force for bad.
And I think also you
have more awareness now
of how all these things relate.
You know, Secretary Kerry
said the other day-- not
to keep quoting him-- but
in an interview said, look,
our view is that the chase
story is the Lang Long story,
or the illegal fishing story
is that sea slavery story.
These are integrated,
connected stories.
And that's the
transshipment point.
The more desperate things
get, the harsher things
are going to get, from a labor
and human rights perspective
and also-- So I'm a
little bit more hopeful
than the series may imply.
Someone else has got
a question, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
governments used
to take a pretty active role.
I mean they would
send ships out there
and they'd hang everyone
they brought in.
Or if they caught you fishing
where you weren't supposed to,
they took your boat and
they tossed you in jail.
What are governments
doing about these things?
Now it sounds like you're saying
that they're largely abdicating
their historical role?
IAN URBINA: Well so I come
down in altitude a little bit.
I don't know if I can answer
for governments writ large.
It varies drastically.
So in the case of Palau, there's
this interesting exchange
we had in the wheel
room with those cops.
And they were kind of
looking at Indonesia
which has a fisheries manager,
this woman named Susi who
has kind of really stepped up.
And part of that
is geopolitical.
And it's Spratly related.
And it's Indonesia
flexing its muscle
saying you come in
our waters, we're
going to do something about it.
But part of it is
genuinely concerned
about human rights and
environmental concerns.
But Indonesia has taken
a very aggressive role.
They catch your
boat, they burn it.
They take you off.
They send you home.
They burn your boat.
The Palauans looked
over at the Indonesians.
They're cops, right?
These are macho
guys and they also
want to succeed in their
job like we all do.
And they were seeing
repeat fliers.
There's this funny anecdote,
didn't make it in the story
but made it in the
second story, about this,
where these guys are at the end
of the day pretty nice guys.
And they're sympathetic
with the deckhands who
are just very poor
guys following orders
on these poacher vessels.
They're not getting
rich from it.
Not even the captain's
getting rich, it's the owner.
And so when they would
arrest the poachers,
they'd bring them back in and
they'd take a clothing donation
from their families.
And oftentimes the
shirts that would end up
in the donated box for
the arrested deckhands
would be campaign shirts.
Why?
Because they're cheap
and they're free.
You know, they're handed
out at each presidential--
The Palauans were saying
that every couple months,
they would see these same
deck hands on other boats
with like elect Smith,
the Palauan Kennedy.
These guys are Filipino
or Taiwanese or whatever,
and they're realizing,
these are repeat fliers,
and this is sort of
really frustrating
because are we really
doing anything here?
They're coming back and
they're coming back.
But to answer your
question, it ranges
from really aggressive
postures like Indonesia
to really permissive postures
like Seychelles and Fiji
that just you can do anything.
And the problem with
maritime enforcement
is it's insanely expensive.
To really do it,
you either need help
from big muscular institutions
like Google in Oceania
or the US government,
US military.
Or if you're on your own,
you need boats and planes.
A lot of these countries
that have the richest waters
don't have boats and
planes to be patrolling.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I sort of have a
similar question
on countries abdicating
their role in a lot of this,
but I think it's interesting
is a lot of the headlines
that we see other than these are
stories about South China Sea
and how a lot of
countries are aggressively
trying to claim territory,
ocean territory, as their own
for their own
geopolitical interests.
So I'm sort of curious
from your perspective,
in some ways it seems
like they wouldn't
want to abdicate this role
because it shows that they
have control over an area.
So I'm curious if you looked
into that part of it at all
or where that overlaps with
what you were interested in.
IAN URBINA: Yeah, so there
are different things going
on there.
So you look at
Spratlys And for those
who haven't been
following it, this
is this area that's
a contested area.
And the Philippines lays claim.
The Chinese lay claim.
And others lay claim.
And the Chinese are the
big boys on the block
and they're building an island.
They're taking ownership.
Possession is 9/10 of
the laws as they say.
And so the Chinese government
has built an island
where there wasn't one and
have now a landing strip.
They have soldiers on there.
Why?
Has nothing do with fishing.
It has to do with
mineral rights.
There's oil and
there's gas and there's
subsea minerals that are
insanely valuable, much
for the computers that we
use, like rare earth stuff,
but also oil and gas.
And that's really
what that's about.
That's what the
Spratlys is about.
And that's really
where governments
tend to flex muscle.
Fishing isn't lucrative
enough, generally
speaking, for countries with big
militaries or navies to care.
Mineral rights, now
you're in big money.
So what you do have
is symbolic clashes
where it seems like it's
over the fisherman who
was shot by that other country.
It's not.
Really it's about
something higher order,
but it's playing out over that.
And so you have
these clashes where
the Vietnamese and the
Indonesians and even
the Palauans will arrest.
So for example
with Palau, there's
this bizarre incident where the
Palauans were really, really
frustrated.
And there was this
one atoll where
they kept spotting this one set
of poachers, day in, day out.
They chased them.
These guys had souped up boats.
They got away.
And finally they went
after them and they tried
to shoot out their engines.
And they say that bullets
ricocheted off the engine.
The guy had four
bullet holes on him.
But a Chinese
deckhand was killed.
And thus began this
dramatic incident,
which is in the story.
But that spurred this
huge diplomatic row
between China and Palau.
And It played out over fishing
rights and mining rights
and tourism subsidy dollars
and all these other things.
And the newspapers focused
on the dead deckhand,
but it really had to do
with much bigger things.
So anyway, to answer
your question,
yeah, countries are exerting
their jurisdictional claims
with their navies when there
is a lot more at stake.
That doesn't usually play
out on a fishing level.
I can talk about this forever.
You guys have a
job to get back to.
So any other questions?
All right, well
thanks for coming.
[APPLAUSE]